joining the show right now from the nfl
network
former green bay packer james joy james
jones is kind enough to join us we
appreciate you having us
uh coming on the show james and and
we're talking about
aaron rodgers not playing in the
preseason big deal no deal what are your
thoughts on
qb 12 not playing
no deal at all we're talking about the
mvp of the league i mean
what's he gonna see in preseason that's
gonna get him ready for the season no
uh no no deal at all man i mean i like
it um and then not only that man you got
to see what these young players got and
god got in front of you man especially
jordan love he
he didn't have the opportunity to play
all last year in pre-season
he's gonna get three of them this year
so you know let him get as much work as
he possibly can to
to get him ready but no i don't think
devonte needs to see none of it aaron
needs to see none of it i don't think
they need to go out there they need to
be ready for week one
as someone who knows that organization
well do you think there's any type of
hangover
around the packers franchise about how
everything with aaron
played out over the summer and the
uncertainty and yes they did get to a
place of
of mutual understanding but is there any
kind of ripple effect from
aaron's conversations with them this
summer
i don't think so uh you know when i was
out there for training camp
it seems like it was past everybody you
know i had a chance to talk to brian the
gm
and mark murphy you know obviously i had
a chance to talk to my
guy aaron and it just seems like it's by
everybody man it's all smiles out there
everybody smiling they know they got an
opportunity
you know a very good football team to
win the super bowl and get back to the
big game
so i think that's it
for all the talent they have on getting
back when i was there it was all smiles
it was it was no sign of
any tension any beef any of that stuff
it was all smiles
we got right here however we had to get
it done and now let's go try to repeat
one
james jones joins the show nfl network
super bowl champ what was it like to see
charles woodson
get enshrined in canton over the weekend
oh man that's my brother man
that's my brother i loved every bit of
it man from him opening up singing to
his mom
you know i'm sure we all know how
special our moms are to us man but you
know
there's something special about them
single moms out there you know holding
down working 24 7 making sure
that kids got it so i loved every bit
about it i loved how he told his kids
man
you know i pray you guys love your mom
like i love mine you know that
that that's huge you know but for me you
know just watching those guys up there
and especially what's it you know with
the tears coming down and
you know all the emotion you know i
always tell my kids all the time man you
see these draft picks crying you see
these hall of fame guys crying i said
it's not because of what happened they
cried because of
the journey that they've been on and and
going back down memory lane and
remembering everything it took for them
to get here
and i was able to be blessed to play
with wilson for eight years you know in
oakland and green bay
and just to see the work that he puts in
man the time the effort the top of it
being the special ass was just
just to sacrifice the work that he puts
in you know each and every week each and
every day
you know every off season it was special
to see my brother get in there
let's go from the green bay packers to
the las vegas raiders
every time i'm in vegas and i see that
stadium sitting right there by the
mandalay bag oh man
it is going to be nuts when fans start
coming
if the team's any good this place is
going to just be insane
you were out at raiders camp what's the
vibe like around the las vegas raiders
i guess how you explained it it's about
to be nuts out there man it's about to
be rocking
uh you know that and that's how they
practice and man the energy the effort
you know it's turnt up out there they
know that
you know fans is coming in the building
you know year four for coach gruden
you know it's time to go to work it's
not time to be eight and eighteen
anymore
you know it's time to go to work you
know with some good pieces over there
that's what they're excited about so
we'll see
man i mean you got a tough test coming
into the building week one and lamar act
uh
gotta bring it this year man but i'm
excited for them excited for dear carl
coach gruden and to see a lot of these
young callers get out here and go to
work
big story yesterday james was michael
thomas and his cryptic tweets and we
were joking in studio or it feels like
it's always a wide receiver
who's always getting oh man what's going
on with you guys man
oh man i don't i don't even like that
tag
man um i haven't
coming into the situation and you know
just what what's all been going
on uh
some stuff you just need to keep house
you know that's it you know without
working out within family you know
whatever
field workout between the family talk to
the coach one-on-one but you know
everybody
you know a special player you know so
hopefully they can keep him happy
because they need him around man you
already lost drew brees you don't need
to leave
lou is arguably the best receiver in the
game you know so whatever they got to do
keep him happy
get this thing rolling when he's back
from his injury so they could they could
get off on the right foot
james jones joins the show nfl network
analyst super bowl champion ben lyons in
for rich on the rich eisen show you
notice how
once i start calling out wide receivers
james's cell phone reception kind of
goes a little spotty
you notice that right it's not by
accident and then all i do is tap a
little thing on my phone and you know
make a static a little bit once you
start talking about the receivers
yeah wide receiver is always the one
having problems sorry i got a bad
connection
hey speaking of another wide receiver i
know you got big expectations for obj
this year in cleveland what are you
expecting for him this season
i do man i just you know talking to him
and being around him man he's just
hungry
and it's not even what he's saying you
know it's just
how he's looking what he's doing you
know you could tell that he's just
mentally ready
you could tell you know because when i
was with him in the giants for that
training camp before i had a chance to
go back to green bay and finish my
career
obj was an absolute dog he didn't care
who throwing the ball
he didn't care what route he was running
just put it over there in my area and i
promise you i'll make the new york
giants look good i make eli manning look
good i make everybody in this place look
good
and we'll win some ball games and when i
talk to him and i see him
that's the mindset he has he's back to
that dog mentality that
you know no matter what's going on hey
swing the ball
my way and i'm gonna make a play and
show everybody that i'm still one of the
best in this game
well well said james there's definitely
a difference in the appetite size
between hungry and
hungry i feel like when guys are hungry
it's just like a deeper level
of wanting to eat so i totally get it
with obj
uh let's stay in the division shall we
um
lamar jackson now diagnosed with covid
for a second time
yet refusing to get vaccinated a
reminder that this is going to be an
issue and a conversation
that will be around this upcoming season
uh
talk to me your thoughts just about
players and their relationships with the
vaccine and when you're hearing
these stories come out of the different
camps uh how does it make you feel
well i mean you know should everybody's
entitled to to doing what they want to
do
man you know having their own opinions
about the shot and things like that
you know my only thing is if you don't
get the shots you don't have to live in
the bubble again
you know the whole season you know it's
no going to restaurants or
doing all that type stuff or you know
getting caught at any events with your
mask off and all that type of stuff
you're going to be getting fined by your
team
by the nfl and all that so you're going
gonna have to live it live in a bubble
so if that's what you want to do
for that season you know and not get the
shots and that's what you want to do
you know for me it's bigger than
me you know like if i'm if i'm around
people every single day and i'm
committed to playing in a football
season
you know and i'm coming home to my two
little kids and my wife
you know i don't want to bring back
nothing to them so if i was playing you
know i would get the shot
as as a purse as a first person for me
now for my teammates i wouldn't be
sitting there judging i wouldn't be
sitting there saying hey man to go
through this go do that because
everybody
you know has their own opinion you know
shoot maybe he's not taking a shot
because you know something bad happened
to somebody that took the shot
i don't know you know so it's a bunch of
stuff that goes on with that but for me
you know if i was still playing in this
game and i said okay look it you know
i'm going out here you know
even though people can still catch cover
but you know i'm committed to playing
you know i would take the shot just so i
could protect my family you know
that would be that would be my my
decision so but for lamar i don't i
don't know if
it's up to him and you know he'll he'll
do what he feels right
it feels right for himself james jones
joining the show nfl network analyst won
a super bowl
and gets to that time of year where some
players start to get that itch they wish
they were back out there
others couldn't be happier that they
don't have two a days on their calendar
every august when it becomes training
camp time what are your thoughts what
are you feeling is there a part of you
that wishes you were still out there or
you have peace with the fact that
you're able to visit these camps with
andrew siciliano instead
hey man i am at peace i i i checked out
the game at the right time
um i know i did because i do not get the
itch to play
i know i joke and talk about it and you
know act like i want to come back but
i am good where i'm at man and it's
crazy you asked me that question because
when i retired
i went back week one to uh watch the
green bay packers play
and i was like man why am i coming to a
game so early i'm gonna walk in here
want to get back in my locker get my
cleats on and go play a game but
it was the opposite man i got there i've
seen jordan them suiting up and all that
and i looked at them and said i'm glad
that you not me brother good luck
stay healthy you know go out there and
do your thing so i know i made the right
decision i'm at peace i'm coaching my
little kids now you know what i mean so
i'm living through them trying to get
them right even though they don't listen
to their daddy they look at me like i
don't know what i'm talking about but
it's all good i'm gonna keep pounding
away at them but no man i have fun
coming to these training camps with
andrew siciliano siciliano
colleen wolf k adams all of them i
have a ball working with them hey james
it's chris brockman
when we get ready looking at the season
who's a team that we're not talking
about that we should be
for me it's the broncos you know every
time somebody
asks me man who's going to be that
surprised see who's going to come out
and
you know have a playoff season and and
we'd be looking like man we weren't
talking about them man for me it's the
broncos you know you
look at this division you know
everybody's high on herbert who i
am you know obviously you got papa
holmes and the chelsea
chiefs you have the raiders and then you
have the broncos i think the broncos
is going to make a lot of noise and not
not only
in this division but in the national
football league i think they're one of
those teams who could
who's going to be when we get close to
the end of the season people are not
going to want to play man you know you
got bob miller
chubb you know you'll have uh teddy
bridgewater in my opinion
you know starting and uh you know not
turning that rock over i think this is
gonna be a really good football game
appreciate the insight as always and
good luck coaching your kids that's got
to be a thrill
for for you and for them we appreciate
you taking some time james
not a problem thanks for having me
fellas hey good morning james jones from
the nfl network
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here